Speaker 1: All right. We already talked about
the Fox News defamation suit is not going to
conclude with with a trial verdict. The trial
started and very quickly they settled it 787 and
a half million dollars. We also talked about
the last minute strategy wherein Fox lawyers
were trying to introduce evidence, essentially
blaming Donald Trump for the claims that were
made on air. Okay. We have now gotten beyond
that. It has been settled. And in writing,
Fox News did walk back the claims that they made.
However, we have also learned for those of us
waiting to see Sean HANNITY grovel and apologize
or Tucker Carlson say we were wrong. They are not
going to have to do that. Part of the settlement
is that Fox News will not have to apologize on air
for broadcasting false claims about Dominion.
Business Insider has a very precise write up about
this. Dominion Voting Systems settled its major
defamation lawsuit on Tuesday. Fox agreed to pay
Dominion 787 and a half million and acknowledged
that the false claims were broadcast. Fox News
hosts will not be required to issue apologies
or retractions on air. Per a source speaking to
Insider. This is part of the negotiation, which
I'm sure was of critical importance to Fox News.
Now, I know that many of you will say. What is
the reason that Dominion would accept this if
that is not going to be part of the settlement?
Why wouldn't Dominion insist that there have to
be on air apologies versus allowing Fox News out
of that? Why wouldn't they say we're not settling,
we're going to trial if you're not going to admit
on air? And the reason is very simple. And I spoke
to a couple of trial attorneys, civil attorneys,
about this over the last 24 hours. Imagine that
your dominion and you bring a $1.6 billion
lawsuit against Fox News and a whole bunch of
time and resources and money have been spent just
even getting to trial. And you're presented with
two options. Option number one is you go through
a 4 to 6 week trial. You might be confident that
you'll get a verdict in your favor with a nice
settlement, but you don't know that for sure.
And even if you do, you then have to collect
it. And there can be appeals and there can be
delays and there can be all sorts of different
things. This could take years. And then you get
to collect whatever you're able to get in a trial
or. Fox News just gives you half of what you asked
for and you probably were already inflating what
you asked for at the beginning, knowing that the
settlement might end up being less. But. But. But
Fox won't have to apologize on air. The answer is
it depends how ego driven this is. If Dominion
is primarily concerned with the sort of punitive
and humiliating nature of getting HANNITY to
apologize on air, then it would make sense to say,
no, that can't be part of the settlement or
we're going to trial or whatever. But my guess
is and it doesn't sound like a crazy decision to
make. My guess is Dominion lawyers said, listen,
this is a sure bet of nearly 800 million and we
wrap it up quickly and we move into collecting the
800 million. But they're not going to apologize on
air. They will apologize in writing. And at least
as far as your future business with states, the
apology in writing is probably pretty good. Why
not just take the 800 million and get the hell
out of here rather than going forward for weeks?
And what could become months or years before
you actually collect? I get it. I get it Now,
as a public person who just has an opinion
as to the destructive and corrosive nature
of what Fox News did around the election on
air. Obviously, I would love to get it sort
of like the perp walk of sorts, right? I would
love to see HANNITY Even if it's a short and
tersely worded apology of some kind, have to
make a statement on air. I would enjoy that.
It would be great. It would be great for the
lulls, as the kids like to say this, that. But
I understand why Dominion wouldn't hold out for
that. So for those of you who are saying, well,
we're now going to get that apology, the apology
came in writing a fox and the article mentioned
this. A Fox spokesperson said in an email, We
acknowledge the court's rulings finding certain
claims about dominion to be false. This settlement
reflects Fox's continued commitment to the highest
journalistic standards. That's hilarious.
We are hopeful that our decision to resolve
this dispute with Dominion amicably instead of
the acrimony of a divisive trial, allows the
country to move forward from these issues. So,
listen, I would have liked to see the apology.
We're not going to get it. And I completely
understand why Dominion is not insisting on that